I had always had a real interest in film
and I've always been really fascinated
by sets so becoming a set decorator was
kind of a natural progression
I started making super 8 films in high
school and that led to undergraduate
study at NYU and this was in the early
80s and New York was really just
abundant with independent film and
non-union low-budget
pictures so it's kind of like a perfect
time to be educated there and I think it
was by my junior year I was allowed to
access this bulletin board on campus
where all these indie films would put up
their their cards looking for PAS and
positions to fill and the object was
always to be the first one there so you
could see the what shows had gone up and
try to get hired before the next guy so
pretty much my last two years of college
were spent in turning on as many films
as I could be a part of and I kept
finding myself when asked choosing to
work for the art departments because I
was starting to feel like that was the
that was the creative hub behind the
film and it was where everybody that was
involved seemed to be creating the the
world that I wanted to be a part of it
seemed like the the place to have to
have fun and to be involved and fulfill
this desire to work on film that led to
me getting my first decorating gig in
the mid-80s I think simply because I was
willing to do it for two hundred and
fifty dollars a week and basically I did
I was the decorator and the construction
coordinator and I painted and dressed
and it led to many more jobs that were
the same way I I think I worked every
position in the art department before
kind of honing in on the decorator as
the position that I admired and more
to pursue I think a lot of people feel
that a set decorator is akin to an
interior decorator and that we are
mostly responsible for having taste and
and doing the shopping and well that
certainly is a part of it it's really
only a small part of what the decorator
does I don't think people are fully
aware of how faceted our position really
is we we really are historians and
anthropologists sociologists I've heard
my my peers refer to this position in in
many different ways but we kind of take
the script and we mine it for details
and we look for ways to to enhance the
environments that of that are part of
our story
in ways that perhaps haven't been
thought of or discovered yet so it
involves a lot of a lot of research a
lot of reading between the lines and
investigating what's not necessarily on
the page to to fully develop a world so
it goes beyond supplying furniture or
objects for a room it and it it really
goes a lot deeper into understanding
every environment in the film and what
those environments need to relay in
order for them to to facilitate the
vision of the film I think the set
decorator is affected by the new
technology in a very subtle way I think
that over the years I see that the tasks
that I am called upon to facilitate on a
show evolving and changing with the
technology but the core the core tasks
that I'm expected to fulfill seem to
remain constant
you could be working on a show that is
3d or involves a being shot on high-def
video or a show that's largely CGI and
all these elements we have to become
proficient in in this language and in
that particular way of seeing and of
making a film but at the same time we
still have a script to break down we
still have to either fabricate or find
the objects with which to address the
sets and and facilitate the the vision
of the film so really every movie is a
crash course in whatever that subject is
that that you have to become adept at
the language of in order to make the
movie so I've learned a great deal over
in the past decade alone of regarding
all the new technologies but I think it
really hasn't changed the way that I do
my job
you